i've been overly fair because
i've been through five pandemics with
him right he was my
he was really my man during hiv
mers sars one
h1n1 h1 was a terrible pandemic you
don't even know what happened that's
what i kept saying
that was bad and you're worrying about
this one like why didn't we have a
moderate reaction to that one at least
why this reaction anyway but uh so i
figured
he had been adulterated by the every
would everyone get adulterated with
which is the tribalism of our time and i
thought he would revert to the mean i
thought his his overall function has
always been like
his judgment has been awesome and i
would see i assume i still to this day
believe we'll see a reversion to the
mean in terms of him looking okay
however
he finally did something that upset me
all right i'm in studio with a live a
real live human being according to the
paperwork dr drew pinsky it is good to
see you my friend good to see you and i
i to be fair i insisted on this i did
you were like no we'll do it by zoom i'm
like no i don't want to do it by zoom
anymore i'm tired of this i've seen this
great studio i want to be in it with you
i want to see you it's good to see ya we
are less than six feet apart so we're
risking everything right now you're
risking everything i'm as immune as i
can possibly be you've had covered like
18 times
i've had the antibodies i've had the uh
injection i've had the vaccine i'm good
and i do something that no one does i
i'm following a very sophisticated
antibody screen with my neutralizing
antibodies and my b cell function so i
can tell you categorically if i get
covered it'd be
reportable do you feel like your life's
work has led to this moment no i don't i
never expected any of this nor do i
really welcome it to be fair but uh but
i i will you know i took the johnson
johnson vaccine myself and i had a nasty
reaction to it really bad i woke up with
a sudden black eye which is called a
raccoon's eye which is the presenting
symptom of transverse sinus thrombosis
which is the dreaded complication
of the uh johnson johnson's faculty i'm
looking in the mirror going oh god damn
it am i gonna have a transverse sinus
thrombosis and nothing so and nothing
you might take another one did you
choose the johnson johnson one time you
did i did i i sort of picked it early
for two reasons one i i react horribly
to viruses horribly to vaccines so i
kind of just wanted one vaccine
silly me now i need another but i i was
hoping just to get by with one also i
like the idea of a sort of an
old-fashioned platform and nothing
against maduro i might even take the
modernity now or the our mrna vaccines
but i just thought eh i react to
everything better i use some old fashion
so before we get to the book which i'm
holding in my hands i'll put it down for
a moment let's just do the the covet
stuff
get it out of here
you've got antibodies you did johnson
and johnson you don't have a problem
with the mrna
is there anything that people should
know about the mrna
is you know we're hearing so much
conflicting stuff and i had dr brian
keating on my show last night last week
talking about that people just don't
trust experts anymore and in many cases
it's the expert's fault right so
particularly the cdc's fault i mean and
the government anybody associated with
public health or cdc has created vaccine
hesitancy they've created it they've
done everything wrong they should have
been from the beginning wide open here's
our thinking here's our concerns here's
the debate we have behind closing here
the all that is how you get people who
are resistant to loosen up and come on
board you treat them like intelligent
people who need to be reasoned with and
you give them all the information you
don't say you can't handle the truth you
can't handle the truth i don't i become
resistant
when what's bizarre to me
is we we learned how to do this during
the hiv epidemic do you i don't know if
i ever told you this i got involved in
radio
because in 1983 one anthony fauci who
was my hero at the time was telling us
young physicians that we had to get out
there and educate and change behavior
because we didn't we couldn't get people
to stop having sex and passing this
virus and i thought i took it very
seriously and we learned across that
that pandemic with a 100 fatality rate
it was the darkest the darkest hours
we learned that the way you change
behaviors is with narratives and
information and showing the consequences
of people's people's choices a little
humor a little music that's how you
change behavior not me in a box pointing
my finger at somebody that's the
opposite right so i've heard you talk
about your experience with fauci then
and and you've been i think very fair to
fouchy i would say almost overly fair
like i've been overly fair because
i've been through five pandemics with
him right he was my he was really my man
during hiv
mers sars one
h1n1 h1 was a terrible pandemic you
don't even know what happened that's
what i kept saying
i was like that was bad and you're
worrying about this one like why didn't
we have a moderate reaction to that one
at least why this reaction anyway but uh
so i figured
he had been adulterated by the every
what everyone's getting adulterated with
which is the tribalism of our time and i
thought he would revert to the mean i
thought his his overall function has
always been like
his judgment has been awesome and i
would see i assume i still to this day
believe we'll see a reversion to the
mean in terms of him looking okay
however
he finally did something that upset me
which was i know if you remember him in
front of congress multiple times
whenever they would ask him about the
gain of function or
funding
he would just be like i'm confused what
are you talking about nothing like two
days ago he goes well you know we did
fun change viral function but we didn't
not this but we were changing vibes
right that was the word why didn't
change what did you tell us that's what
we were
that's how you create vaccine hesitancy
now it's like okay i can't trust you you
knew we were asking answer the damn
question be open about this trust the
american people to be able to digest
what you're telling them and give them a
recommendation and then move on so do
you think in essence he lied under oath
to grant
i don't really have an opinion about
that so much just because change of
seems to be the word that he's you can't
do that right now you've got to be open
and honest you cannot obfuscate this is
dissembling you can't whether it's you
know lying or you know
worthy of sort of further investigation
i have no opinion it's dissembling it's
obfuscating you can't be that way now
that's how you create vaccine hesitancy
i've gotten to the point now where i'm
telling people
your problem i've talked to lots of
vaccine hesitant people your problem is
you don't know who to trust so here's
what i want you to do i want you to find
if it's for the kids find a pediatrician
for it's you find an internist that you
trust and you sit down with that person
and you too
make that medical decision the way we're
supposed to make all [ __ ] medical
decisions the fact that anybody has an
opinion about what a doctor does with
his patients is offensive and disgusting
the fact that anybody has opinion about
what joe rogan doctor does with him
that's disgusting now other physicians
can have opinions about it and we can
discuss it professionally but for people
in the world to interfere with that
relationship that is disgusting and why
people aren't more upset about the
adulteration of the relationship between
doctors and patients i i'm i'm
gobsmacked yeah no i can see it look i i
know you pretty well off camera too i'm
pretty sure i've never heard dr drew or
my friend
say that yeah i'm upset so so i get it
so not that i don't say it
but so you you put a pretty party on
here i find my best behavior i do all
right you know uh but so to that end i
mean i assume i've heard you talk about
a little bit are you a hundred percent
against mandates as a as a general rule
is you never say always and never you
just never do that so am i against
mandates generally yes absolutely i'm
against the idea that this now i
understand that we need to do things to
urge populations to do certain things i
don't see where it's there look i was in
front you've been in france recently
it's very it's only been in france once
it was in 1997. i suggest you go back
there now because it's very interesting
what's happening there what's happening
there they have same mandates we have
essentially
they apply it very differently when you
go to the louvre you can show your eu
pass or go over there get a test if
you'd like whatever you want and or you
can show us your antibodies from your
natural immunity
rational that's not a man there's a
mandate but a rational application of a
mandate and the really interesting thing
is the youth are fighting
like crazy so 18 to 28 year olds are in
the streets by the thousands yeah you
don't see that on cnn vive la liberte is
their call this is that i've spoke to my
french is pretty good i spoke to a lot
of them because i was intrigued and like
young people not asking for more mask
wearing i might understand they were
furious and their position was look
you've educated us rightly that this
thing is not a major risk to us now
you're mandating us put something in our
bodies we may choose to do it and you
can help us make that decision if you
think it's so mandating it no
and it's it's it's echoes of 1790. i'm
telling you they will they bring up the
same language as 1790 they raise their
fists and they've got a history of
beheading over there well i don't think
this is that kind of mob action yeah but
that's going on here you know it's
called cancel culture if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell